The "Mortal Kombat" series is known for infamously
violent fatalities and a deep roster of badass
fighters from realms across the multiverse.
Translating these fighting games into movies
is no easy task.
Here are the five best and five worst scenes
in 2021's "Mortal Kombat."
"Mortal Kombat" puts its best foot forward
in an opening that takes place centuries before
the rest of the movie.
Sub-Zero comes to Hanzo Hasashi's home to
assassinate him and his family.
After seeing his son and wife killed and frozen
by the cryomancer, Hanzo goes on a rampage,
tearing through a legion of assassins with
his iconic Kunai rope.
This leads to an epic showdown between the
two.
The actors playing the iconic "Mortal Kombat"
duo - Joe Taslim and Hiroyuki Sanada - are
veterans of martial arts and samurai cinema.
The bouts between them are by far the highlight
of the 2021 "Mortal Kombat" adaptation, and
the first one gets the movie off to a rousing
start.
Sub-Zero walks away the victor, leaving Hanzo
dead as the screen fades to black and the
title card fades in.
It's time for "Mortal Kombat."
A strength of the latest "Mortal Kombat" is
the direction and choreography of its hand-to-hand combat.
Unfortunately, this means the scenes where
the actors have to fight against a CGI opponent
stick out like a sore thumb amid the visually
superior physical action.
The worst of these is a warehouse fight where
Cole, Sonya Blade, and Kano face off against
an invisible human-sized reptile.
Seeing the actors fight against air definitely
breaks the believability of the scene.
When their adversary is invisible, the effects
aren't convincing enough to give you a solid
sense of its scope or location; when we do
get a glimpse, it still doesn't seem like
much more than a generic beast.
Once Kano punctures the lizard with a flare,
he becomes a whole lot easier to see and well...
you know what's coming next.
Still, even when the cast isn't punching at
nothing, the scene doesn't manage to excite.
The special effects on the lizard don't look
especially stylish or cool.
The end result is the most forgettable fight
of the entire movie.
Eagle-eyed "Mortal Kombat" fans undoubtedly
noticed from trailers that early on in the
movie Jax is lacking his defining characteristic
- his two cyborg arms.
It doesn't take long for the movie to show
the traumatic incident that caused Jax's epic transformation.
The early scenes where Jax has both his human
arms can be interpreted as a nod to "Mortal
Kombat II," the game where the character made
his debut.
In the 2021 "Mortal Kombat ” Sub-Zero is
the one responsible for Jax's dismemberment.
After hunting down Jax, Cole, and his family,
Sub-Zero lures Jax into battle.
The two have an intense combat session that
leads to a pretty gnarly time for Jax when
Sub-Zero freezes his arms until they explode
into a bloody mess of ice and viscera.
In the middle of the film, Liu Kang finds
Cole, Sonya, and Jax in the desert and the
movie decides the real plot should start now.
The legendary protector takes the crew to
Raiden's temple where the Earthrealm protectors
have the entire backstory of "Mortal Kombat"
and Outworld explained to them.
Liu Kang tells the protectors about the tournament
and that's kind of his role for the entire movie.
It is a major letdown to have the main hero
of a majority of the "Mortal Kombat" series
relegated to doling out exposition and training
the characters that actually get to fight.
In less than 10 minutes of its total runtime,
"Mortal Kombat" introduces three major characters
and sets up the conflict for the rest of the
adventure.
It's a rushed scene full of exposition that
reiterates information that most "Mortal Kombat" fans already know.
Despite being squeezed between two action
sequences, this scene still manages to kill
the momentum in the middle of the movie.
Cole unlocks his true potential when the four-armed
Goro is about to kill his family.
With wife Alison and daughter Emily in harm's
way, Cole taps into his arcana, his body turning
into an energy-absorbing armor not unlike
the "Black Panther" costume.
Sure, the CGI-heavy fights in "Mortal Kombat"
aren't the best, but the final moments of
this sequence more than make up for that.
When tapping into his power, Cole materializes
his weapons and proceeds to absolutely go
to town on Goro.
Only one of Cole's weapons is bladed, but
it definitely feels like they're an homage
to Tanya's in "Mortal Kombat: Deception" and
"Armageddon."
Kano is the ultimate loudmouth and this scene
is him at his swear-iest, angriest, and most
overtly racist.
Kano exudes machismo and spews some serious
anti-Asian sentiments as Kung Lao and Liu
Kang egg him on to try and see his true power.
It's only then that we see Kano's laser eye
in action for the first time in the movie.
The scene goes way overboard on how offensive
Kano acts to the point where it begins to
give away the twist that happens later on.
There's no way you are supposed to root for
Kano after this.
If it wasn't obvious Kano was destined to
betray the protectors to Shang Tsung, this
scene makes it painfully clear that he is
not a good guy.
Fighting games are known for creating some
of the biggest character rivalries in gaming,
and Sonya and Kano go way back as storied
rivals.
Additionally, fans of the original 1995 movie
are sure to be reminded of the pair's classic face-off.
The new movie leans hard into Kano being a
foul-mouthed scumbag.
He's always been known for being cunning and
untrustworthy.
The latest portrayal of Kano is no different,
as he betrays Sonya and the heroes of Earthrealm
by removing the shield of protection around
the Raiden's temple - betraying Sonya's trust most of all.
This relationship makes the final showdown
between the two supremely satisfying.
When Sonya finally unleashes her garden gnome-based
fatality on Kano, she earns her dragon mark
and finally becomes the protector of Earthrealm
she was destined to be.
Not long after the protectors make it to Raiden's
temple, Sonya discovers Jax is alive and being
cybernetically enhanced.
As he recovers, Jax struggles with getting
accustomed to his new body.
Thankfully Sonya is there to give a motivational
speech that works wonders for Jax, but leaves
the audience a bit cold.
The attempt to develop this crucial "Mortal
Kombat" relationship is a bit "too little too late."
While Sonya and Jax are indeed partners and
have a close friendship in the games and comics
lore, the connection doesn't come across as
well in the newest movie.
Sonya's words of motivation clue into the
duo's military background together, but the
monologue doesn't land on an emotional level
and falls flat as the movie barrels forward.
In the biggest twist of the whole movie, Cole's
ancestor warps back from the depths of the
Netherrealm to finally defeat Sub-Zero once
and for all.
Right before Sub-Zero is about to deal a death
blow to Cole, Hanzo's Kunai lodges its way
into his arm before the ancient hero lets
loose his iconic battle cry.
It wouldn't be a "Mortal Kombat" movie without
at least one "get over here," now would it?
"Get over here!"
It is once again worth mentioning how fantastic
the action and choreography are in the scenes
featuring these two martial arts film stars.
The climactic action sequence fully delivers
on being one of the best in the movie, featuring
weapons, fists, and magic powers in equal
measure.
Hanzo fully makes the transition to Scorpion
and finishes Sub-Zero with the fire breath
fatality "Mortal Kombat" fans remember from
way back in the day at the arcades.
It is hard to top the climactic battle between
Scorpion and Sub-Zero, but "Mortal Kombat"
wraps up so quickly and abruptly it's hard
not to feel like you fell asleep or missed something.
Of the final scenes, the one that feels most
rushed is the confrontation between the leaders
of each realm: thunder god Lord Raiden versus
the evil Shang Tsung.
It ends up being less of a confrontation and
more of a short conversation.
After it becomes clear that Raiden and the
forces of Earthrealm have defeated their Outworld
foes, Shang Tsung teleports into the scene
to tell the heroes the fight is not over yet.
He swears he will get his revenge, and then
it looks like Raiden is preparing to battle
in one last epic fight.
But that is ... not what happens.
Instead, Raiden uses a lightning blast to
send Shang Tsung back to Outworld, buying
time to gather more allies for the sequel.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
action movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.